back from lunch everyone uh so the first
talk of the afternoon will be by megal
Gupta on air
[Applause]
correction okay yeah as galani said I'm
gonna talk to you about error correction
for message streams my name is migle and
this is based on joint work with Rachel
Zing okay so I guess I'll start by uh
defining the problem so like in a
standard
in the standard sorry in the standard
setting of communication Alice has an
message message X that she wants to send
to Bob and then Bob wants to Output like
X and that means that he's received the
message so in the streaming analog of
communication Alice is still going to
send a message X to Bob but now instead
of outputting all of X because like he
doesn't have space d or all of X he is
just going to Output some
function f ofx and f ofx is some
function that like can be computed and
the final output is in significantly
less space than x we'll say that
throughout the talk that X is in 01 to
the n and for example one thing that uh
Bob could be Computing is f could
correspond to some arbitrary Y in 01 to
the n and F
ofx could be y dox
so like f could be some arbitrary linear
function so in this case for example Bob
would be able to compute F which is
equal to y.x in log space because he has
to store like the index I that he's
currently on as well as like a running
sum and I'm considering all of these in
like
F2 does that make
sense okay so what is like the standard
setting of error correction so in the
standard setting of error correction
Alice wants to send a message to
Bob such that he is still able to Output
X in face of like a small constant
fraction like Delta fraction of
Errors so Delta
fraction so now instead of sending X
directly Alice is going to have to send
an encoding which we call ECC of
X so does that make sense uh so like the
main question that we're going to be
discussing in this talk is what happens
uh what is can you do the same thing can
you error correct in the streaming
setting so what is the analog of the
question in the streaming
setting so we want Alice to send
something to Bob such that Bob is still
able to Output y.x right now we'll just
consider linear functions but at the end
of the talk we'll go back a little bit
to General
functions um so Al want to send
something some encoding to Bob such that
he's still able to output y.x and he's
still able to compute this value
in or in sorry in poly log
space so if Alice were just if Alice
just sent like Bob a standard error
correction or standard error correcting
code then the problem is Bob would need
to First decode ECC of X and then
compute and then uh like compute y.x so
that isn't actually low space because
Bob actually needs to store the entirety
of ECC in part of his protocol right so
the question that we're gonna be
discussing is whether there actually is
like an analog of this concept for the
streaming model because it's not at all
obvious that I guess the I guess this
sort of highlights the reason why the
question is inherently different in the
streaming model than in the standard
model because uh in the streaming mod in
the standard model you can actually just
send like a global error crafting code
and then decode the entire thing at once
but here you can't actually use that
solution so can you can you do this
question yeah so the errors adversarial
they can cluster in the beginning or
yeah so the the errors here can be
adversarial the ad the adversary will uh
know what x is beforehand as well as
know what process Alice is using to
encode X and um based on this can decide
to corrupt to concentrate all the
Corruptions at the beginning if they
want Bob knows why without pay in space
um Bob's algorithm is allowed to depend
on why so yeah I guess in some sense he
knows why without paying any
space so does the model make
sense okay so the main theorem that
we're
gonna discuss in this
talk is the
following the main I guess the main
thing we're going to do is we're going
to answer this question the affirmative
we're going to say that this encoding
does actually exist theorem is that
there exists an
encoding that goes from messages of
length n to encodings of
length uh approximately n squar uh this
n squ is not necessarily tight but this
encoding uses length n squ like there
might be better en codings and that's
going to be an open question
[Applause]
later such
that Bob can um
let say Bob can
[Applause]
compute um such that Bob can compute y.x
and polylog n space
given 1/4 Minus Epsilon
error adversarial error with high
probability
all right does the theorem statement
make
sense
okay yeah so I guess now we're gonna the
the main I guess yeah so 1/4 Minus
Epsilon is the value of delta from
beforehand yeah that's the value of
delta from beforehand I guess I won't be
too careful about chasing this exact
constant though in the in the outline
I'm going to give right now um so I
guess it's a brief outline of the rested
talk we're going to prove this the proof
is not actually that complicated but I
guess this talk is not actually that
long either
um and then I'm going to spend a little
bit of time talking about open problems
because like this model is is like a new
model it's just like what is what can
you do for like what can you do for
error correction in the streaming model
that you could do in the original model
and what can't you do that you could do
in the standard model so I'm going to
discuss a few open questions but really
like anything you can do in this
standard model is probably fair game and
like those are all reasonable open
questions to work on yeah do you
construct this encoding or do you just
show that it exists uh we construct the
encoding okay uh does that does that
seem reasonable I don't know can I move
on okay
cool okay so let's start
like looking for this
encoding so uh earlier we talked about
like why sending just a standard error
correcting code doesn't work right
because it's sort of like too Global
like you actually need to know know all
of ECC ofx at once right so like the
next natural thing to try I guess is an
LDC the reason that an LDC is natural is
because it has like more of like like
you don't have I guess you don't have to
do like the same like storing of the
entire thing at once storing of the
entire like error correcting code at
once in order to be able to do some sort
of
decoding so uh the first thing we're
going to try is have Alice just send LDC
of x to Bob uh let's define what an LDC
is so we're going to be using polylog
query
yeah a locally decodable
code so we're gonna Define
it okay so an LDC uh is a locally
decodable code uh we're gonna be using
polylog query ldcs so let's say what
that means so an LDC is an
encoding um that Maps strings of length
n to strings of length slightly longer
than N I think in this case they're
going to be like o Tilda of n but it
doesn't like really
matter um and importantly they're going
to have the following
properties Bob can
recover a
single bit
XI with poly
log
and
queries what that means is uh he can he
has a randomized process for choosing
like poly log and locations of uh of the
encoded message and just querying those
locations and uh then he can recover
XI the reason that this is important is
because it also means that if he
receives LDC in a streaming manner he
only needs polylog and bits of space in
order to recover XI because they're only
poly log and like indices that he
actually needs to ever read
so that's uh the reason that we're going
to be trying to use ldcs at the base of
our construction because they a way to
decode there sort of a way to do
decoding while uh while only using a
small number of while using only a small
amount of space so the problem though is
that like uh Bob can only recover a
single bit this way importantly this is
resilient error so
resilient to 1/4 Minus FS
[Applause]
error
yeah so like I guess the the thing that
we would hope for I guess if we actually
wanted to go back and compute y.x the
problem is we would need to recover all
of X1 through xn using the same LDC
that's not actually okay because then
you would have to go back to needing uh
Theta of n space right but like you can
recover a single bit you can only
recover a single bit using this method
that's why this is not actually
okay so let's try another attempt that
doesn't really
work
let's have Bob Alis and sorry let's have
Alis and LD like end copies of of a
locally decodable code LGC ofx and then
in the first one Bob is going to recover
X1 uh the second one he's going to
recover X2 and the last one he's going
to recover
xent um so this would work so if every
single copy of LDC were only corrupted a
little bit like every single copy were
were corrupted less than a fourth then
um Bob could use these Val values to
keep track of a running sum and compute
y.x right but that doesn't actually work
because the adversary can choose to
corrupt this entire message and then uh
X1 will be decoded incorrectly right and
then at the end Bob will in fact output
potentially an incorrect
answer so the main thing we're going to
try to do with our construction is try
to get around this issue so that
um Bob will actually be able to compute
X so that Bob will actually be able to
recover each of these XIs uh on average
correctly like all of the XIs on average
correctly instead of just instead of
like only being able to recover like
half of them
correctly but we're gonna still use
copies of LDC as our base
construction um okay so to do this we're
going to Define like let's look at
what's going on in terms of a tree
structure like the final construction is
going to be recursive in some sense so
the the function that Bob is Computing F
which is like y dox can be broken into
two
parts
uh it's we're going to write it as F1 of
X Plus F2 of X where F1 is like the
first half of of of uh Y and F2 is the
second half of Y so like this is like uh
like
y1 so I guess you can think of this as
like y1 X1 dot dot dot y n over two x n
over two and F2 of X is like the second
half right
what's uh does that make
sense yeah so in a tree structure what's
going on here is Bob is Computing F1 and
F2 and here he's like splitting this
again Computing f11 F12 dot dot dot and
then at the base level he's Computing XI
doyi for some values of for some value
of I right um if you're trying to look
at like what he's doing over over
[Applause]
here so the issue is that the adversary
can take a single one of these leaves
and destroy it
right so uh what we're gonna do instead
is try to make the average so the
problem is that the adversary is like
you know corrupting F1 and not F2 here
right so what we're going to try to do
is uh instead make it so that the
adversary doesn't know when F1 and when
F2 are being computed so he can't
actually Target he can't actually Target
errors on only one of them so we're
going to do is we're going to add like a
bunch more
uh like leaves here and we're going to
have the adversary or we're going to
have Bob
compute
um F1 and F2 both a bunch of times so
Bob is gonna have like a lot of leaves
in this tree let's say like we we'll
specify the exact amount later but let's
say like log leaves log and leaves and
he's going to compute F1 half the time
and F2 half the time in some randomized
way that that the adver AR has no idea
of so the adversary cannot concentrate
errors on only F1 or only F2 and then
the adversary is going
to go ahead and or and then Bob is going
to go ahead and recurse this process so
now he's going to compute f11 a bunch of
times F1 two a bunch of
times or I guess these are
twos and so on and then basically like
uh we're going to have the same base
nodes the same base nodes of XI doyi but
now the point is like you don't actually
need all of the base nodes to be correct
you just need that on average they're
correct like once let's let's look at
like the top layer again so in this
layer the way that Bob is going to
determine uh the value of F1 at the end
is he's just going to take the majority
of all of these outputs and that's going
to be his value of F1 so it wasn't it
wasn't necessary that all of the outputs
were correct but just that the majority
was correct um makes
sense yeah so I guess if you do the
computation out it turns out that the
number of children you need is poly log
n in order to guarantee that as you as
you go down through the layers that
actually all of these that actually F1
will be correct and F2 will be correct
um it turns out the number of leaves you
need per layer is poly logen which would
give uh a total amount of which would
mean that the total number of nodes at
the base
were poly log n to the power of log n
because like the total size of the tree
would be this quantity so I guess I
promised you something slightly
different I promised you uh that the
number of nodes at the base would be
Theta of n because like each LDC is also
like approximately length n so then that
would give you the N squar from like the
theorem
statement so uh this is like slightly
different from this quantity the way to
fix that is actually pretty simple right
now we have like we have F being split
into two parts F1 and and F2 uh instead
we could split it into poly log n parts
and in essence that would mean that the
number of layers goes instead of being
log in the number of layers is log based
polylog of
N and if you're careful about your
constants you can get you would be able
to get Thea n for the number of nodes
yeah I like how come he couldn't have
just um for every bit tried to decoded
like login times but at random times and
then every bit with good probability
could have been corrupted to many times
so are you suggesting sort of
like I guess oh yeah I guess that sort
of comes into play with the memory so
the point is like when Bob is Computing
F2 over here he actually like doesn't
need to store any of the memory from the
base recursion of F1 right and that's
where his memory Advantage is coming in
yeah so I guess I should have been clear
about like why this is actually poly log
and memory but it's just because every
time he's Computing F2 he doesn't need
to store any of the nodes of F1 so at
any point you sort of are only storing
One path on the three on the on the tree
[Applause]
um okay does that does that make
sense
yeah what's the output the output length
is just is just a constant because like
it uh F2 is just is just uh F2 or F1 is
just like this quantity here like y1 X1
dot dot dot YN over two xn over two so
the output is just a
constant you mean the sum oh yeah yeah
it's just the sum sorry yeah
okay yeah so the output so I guess uh
the things you're going to need to store
are you would need to store like you
would need to store every every value
you've computed of F1 so far so that you
can take the majority at the end you can
do a slight hack to not actually have to
do that but like more or less you're
gonna have to do that and then and
you're a to do the same thing for F2 but
that's like not a whole lot of memory
that's like approximately log
memory so if my function f is not a uh
so it's my function f it's not a DOT
product but a streaming algorithm I
should Syle F1 as the intermediate
memory State yeah I see yeah so I guess
the issue with the general with the
general um function would be that uh in
order to that would be that like in
order to be able to do these
computations out of order you actually
need like F2 to not depend on F1 oh yeah
so I guess in order for this protocol
exactly is stated to work you would you
would in fact need that property which
is why I wanted to only go over for DOT
product because uh because yeah
otherwise you run into that
issue you cannot do
arbitrary this way you cannot do
arbitrary cryptographic digest or
something so it has to be linear
operator okay so actually the theorem
statement that we prove in the paper is
a Little Bit Stronger um we actually are
able to get arbitrary functions um there
the the only caveat for the arbitrary
functions is that they actually have to
be
deterministic and uh the and the caveat
is that instead of getting n squ you end
up getting n the 4th um so this
construction here has the issue that
like you need F you need to know the
value of F1 before F2 but you can do
something where you just take your like
best guess for F1 and you can prove that
like it works but it takes longer to
converge so that's why you need n4th
instead of n to the fourth instead of n
squ is that like sort of clear I I don't
really want to go into the details of
that sorry okay I think that wasn't
clear then okay I guess the let me State
like a different theorem there's a
different theorem in the paper which
says that you can compute any function f
of you can compute any function f of x
in s. poog n space where F ofx in the
noisess setting would take s space to
compute and uh instead of n s over here
you would have an N to the 4th over here
but I'm not going to go over the proof
of that right
[Applause]
now okay so I think that's like most of
the math I wanted to cover so I wanted
to like say some of the open questions
and uh you guys should work on them
because I think they're interesting
[Applause]
questions
so the first
one is
uh is what communication blowup is
needed so in the theorem we said earlier
and the construction we described the
amount of communication that Alice needs
to send is n squ right like it's uh it's
quadratic in the length of the original
message X so the question is can you do
this in linear I don't know if a lower
bound that shows that you can't and like
maybe you actually can so uh yeah so the
first question is can you do that like
even just for the dot product case even
in just like the linear linear function
do product case can you do n squar and
or sorry can you do theta of N and also
what's the best you can do in the in the
general case can you just get n Theta of
n for all of them I don't know like
maybe also maybe there's a lower bound
against
it um so the second one is concerning a
different function other than do
product um so I guess the second one is
going to be about space
blowup so um the general the general
theorem is that for any function s or
for any function that F that used s
space the uh space of this algorithm
will be like stimes poly log
[Applause]
n so in the case where like in the case
where like
um s was already pretty big like s was
already log n or poly log n maybe this
isn't that concerning right like poly
log n is not that much bigger than n but
in the case where uh s were like a lot
smaller like you could imagine there are
functions where s is log log n then this
is actually a pretty big blowup so in
that case is like the poly log n
necessary so an example of such a
function is the following
um you have Alice who has an input X and
Bob has I and he wants to Output XI so
if Alice just naively sends over X then
this would take Bob like log space
because he would need to like count uh
he would actually need to like count the
in sorry he would need to count the
indices of the input but actually
there's a message that Alice can send to
Bob so that um this process only
requires log n space Alice can send J
comma XJ for all uh values of J between
one and n and then in order to check and
then in order to decide whether to
Output XJ Bob just needs to check does I
equal
J to
Output
XI Bob
checks does J equal I and then if J
equals I then he just outputs the next
bit right and J but J is only length log
log
n uh like because like the index itself
is length log log n so Bob only needs to
check uh if all of the bits of that log
log n Lane string are equal to all the
bits of his string uh so actually this
process only requires log log n Bits and
uh I guess a concrete question about
space is can you find an encoding so
there is a way to send uh and message X
across such that Bob can output XI and
log log n Bits is there a way to send it
send X across uh so that in the face of
error Bob can output XI in log log in
poly log log n
Bits yeah so I guess that's another
interesting question I don't know of a
way to do that faster than uh poly logn
because the space of this low up is poly
log
in yeah maybe it's just me I I didn't
get why
index was
it right okay so J uh J is some number
between um
[Applause]
one for some reason okay
sorry oh yeah sorry so J is some number
between one and N so J requires log n
Bits to store I think I I think I
explained it incorrectly so you were
right to catch me on that so J requires
log n Bits
so J is in
01 to the log n um and in order to
determine if a length log n if two
length log n strings are equal I claim
that only log log n Bits of memory are
necessary
[Applause]
um yeah and then you because you just uh
you just keep a counter yeah you just
keep a counter to go through this entire
string and through this entire string
and check if they're equal so you're
right I I in fact messed up what the
this exponent
was yeah so the question is can you do
this problem and can you preserve the
log log andness of the memory of this
problem and I I'm sure there's like tons
more interesting problems because like I
don't know I guess you can ask a lot of
questions that you ask about regular uh
regular er correcting codes in the case
of in the case of like streaming algor
in the case of like message streams so
yeah I guess that's my talk you guys
should try the problems I don't know I
think they're good yeah I think this is
a really basic question I still know
like if you were just
a I have a feeling it's gonna like point
out I know very little about Eric coring
codes but if you're just in the locally
decodable Cold Case the space complexity
is what like it's I'm assuming it's
better than log in because otherwise
your question too would be pretty hard
right uh like let's say I just wanted to
find one bit you know like yeah is a SP
yeah I mean I think for locally
decodable codes you probably need log
memory because even because I guess even
if you were able to get like short
locally decodable codes you would still
need to be able to count indices into
the like as as the way we know how to do
locally decodable codes you need to like
count bits in you need to actually be
able to count the length of the stream
like the important thing about like
trying to break the login barriers you
can't actually count into the stream
anymore so you're it would have to be
like even something that goes beyond
locally decodable yeah I would have to
use something different than locally
decodable codes or somehow get around
like actually counting into the locally
decodable code I guess you could try to
get around counting into the locally
yeah I guess you have to literally you
mean like you have to decide where to
access it and that takes login bits
already yeah yeah exactly I understand
okay
thanks yeah so like maybe it's just not
possible but like I don't know I guess
then you could try to prove it's not
possible
yeah so can you tell me what this s is
it's the space needed to compute F
ofx yeah space to
compute F ofx without
[Applause]
error so like in in the setting I guess
in the setting where you just had Alice
sending a message X to
Bob and then how fast can he output F
ofx without
error like how much space does it take
him to Output F ofx without error I
guess even in this setting Alice is
allowed to potentially encode her
message into like some different message
M
ofx but like the point is there's no
error so so s is just the space needed
in order for Bob to compute F ofx uh in
this in the in the setting without her
so could you take take me through why in
this like J or like this iix I case it
would be log log instead of log right
yeah so I guess this is maybe because I
didn't really Define this well earlier
but um even in the original even in the
case without error Alice is allowed to
encode her message because we're
allowing her to encode it in the like
error case so why not in this case so
instead of sending X directly Alice is
going to send J comma XJ for all values
of J ranging from one through n and then
Bob is going to try to figure out what
XI is given those as his given those as
his message bits instead of like X1
through xn as his message bits
okay so it's like the it's the sort of
amount of information needs to go over
the channel in the noisess case oh s is
the amount of space Bob is going to take
Bob the amount of memory that Bob has
not the amount of
communication wait so how does uh how
does this handle with like Bob because I
still takes like the integer I that Bob
has to have still takes login space
right so how do we yeah so I guess Bob's
algorithm is Bob's algorithm is going to
depend on I but not actually going to
store ey he can't store ey because it's
too much space right gotcha okay yeah
yeah so his algorithm is going to depend
on I I guess you could also think of it
as he has read access to I um yeah but
the point is like yeah I it is it is
true that I will not count in his memory
okay cool thank
youel um I guess I'm wondering is there
any sort of version of the problem where
maybe doesn't see X all at once but
rather gets X
herself some online manner maybe after
weekend the adversary in that case but
is there any model where that might make
sense where she can encode what she sees
so far in s to Bob and then
can yeah I think that's an interesting
question yeah I don't know the answer to
that one I think I think that would be
interesting to
answer I guess like in the normal in the
in the like non in in the like
non-streaming version there's some like
tree codes right that that sort of do
this
thing so I wonder if you can make tree
codes like low memory tree
[Applause]
codes so you erased the theorem but it
seems to me that the parameters of your
uh scheme were very close to parameters
of the LDC that you are using so is
there a generic version of the theorem
where if you have an LDC with these many
errors these length you get um error
correction message streams with this
many errors and this length
yeah so I guess for the uh for the
linear case uh for the case of like
linear uh yeah for the case where the
function Bob is trying to compute as
linear you need a a communication of
like Theta of like Theta Tila of n times
the length of the LDC and I think the I
think the amount of space you're going
to need is like a lot of poly is still a
lot of poly logs times like the space of
the LDC and I think it'll be like n
cubed and like a lot of poly logs for
General fun functions and what about the
the error and I guess my question is
yeah so the error is actually the same
as the LDC error if the if the LDC is
resilient to uh like Delta R then you'll
get Delta minus Epsilon need to be
adversarial because it seems here that
you're basically randomizing the errors
so if I give you an LDC with say better
error but randomized errors so you
assume you have an LDC that can take a
quarter of adversar chosen errors but
actually here you don't care because
you're randomizing everything right so I
give LDC that's good enough with let's
say
half random errors or something is that
would that also work or I think the
thing is the adversary can still Target
like like these base nodes are still
going to be ldcs right so I think the
adversary can still adversarially
correct within an LDC the point of the
recursion is that the adversary can't
Target decide which ldcs to corrupt more
the adversary can still say like I'm
going to corrupt all the ldcs like
exactly one half and then do adversarial
corruption within the
LDC Maybe there's like some way of of
like
randomizing what LDC you're using but I
feel like that might involve like shared
Randomness I guess the point is like
this is only saying that like you can
make the adversary not really be able to
predict which copies of LDC that are
going to be important but like you can't
uh actually this isn't actually like
making the errors within the ldcs look
[Applause]
random
any further
questions thank this
week we have a break until